you recently read Ray Dalio 'he's new
chapter that he released chapter 2 for
his new book and he wrote a a pretty
deep dive on basically why you what do
you think he got wrong right so he spent
a little bit of time kind of talking
through that may mentioned it earlier
but just you know what your takeaways
were and kind of what do you think he
got right well I think so I'll hit on a
couple pieces number one he talks about
you know understanding money debt and
credit and all that sort of stuff but
then you know he he starts with that but
then he gives like such a really weak
definition of what money is he's like oh
you know money is a medium exchange and
it's also some some sometimes used as a
store hold of wealth I was reading that
I'm like what like you can't exchange
something that doesn't that's not you
know valuable in the first place so it's
like that you know it doesn't make sense
and I sort of argued that unless you
give you know a much deeper definition
of money the whole argument that is
entire chapter sits on just falls apart
so you know I kind of like to define
money as something deeper it's you know
it's a mechanism via which participants
in society can effectively collaborate
like if you don't have that mechanism
society goes out the window you can't
like you know money is used to represent
the products of one's time and labor in
other words you know their work and any
if you don't get that depth you don't
appreciate how important money is and
then you can you know call it something
as stupid as I it's just the medium of
exchange so that sort of where he starts
off then he starts talking about you
know you know yeah money doesn't have
intrinsic value blah blah blah but then
he turns around and starts to talk about
how gold became money because it has
intrinsic value and then I was like
facepalming myself again I'm like okay
there's no such thing as intrinsic value
all value it's subjective simple of that
like and like that the example that I
like to use is you know we all value air
right like the ability to breathe but if
you have a child and you're both let's
say in a in a car accident and you fall
off a bridge and you're in the water and
only one of you is going to be able to
breathe what are you gonna value more in
that moment I know this is a brutal
example but you're gonna value air or
you're going to value your child's life
so it's it's a very what that means is
that at that point in time that the
value you place on air is much lower
than though you place on you know your
child's life for example so it's all
value is subjective now Gould didn't
become money because of some notion of
intrinsic value it has specific
attributes that we converged upon as
human beings to say that hey that is a
really good object to represent the time
and work that I'm trading for money so
that was another area then there was a
couple sections that made him agreed on
he talks about how central banks are
able to rig the game then he's 100%
right because that's one of those things
with I can see it was highlighted in my
article you know whilst the rest of us
idiots spend our two finite resources
time and energy to to receive money in
return you know there's a few
organizations who just gets to change
the rules for themselves at the expense
of the rest of us and it's just it's um
it's madness then what else did I hit
things about where he talked to you okay
so he mentions a section in there while
the virus triggered this particular
financial and economic downturn
something else would have eventually
triggered it which I agree with and
regardless of what it did the dynamic
value would have basically been the same
because only intervention would have
worked to reverse the downturn
and I kind of really like poked at that
which is we didn't actually reverse the
downturn I actually think we've just
accelerated the downturn by intervening
again we didn't actually fix anything
we broke the [ __ ] even more than it was
broken before so the correction for this
Korona crash or whatever we're going to
label it as was the system fixing itself
and instead of getting out of the way
and allowing the system to fix fix
itself we just doubled down on breaking
the [ __ ] thing and for me when I see
someone who's supposedly you know as
intelligent or whatever is raised to
assume that these interventions are some
form of solution just baffles me because
that's it's not what we're doing like we
can't perpetuate that narrative because
all we're doing is running the same game
against like the narrative has to be
the the system is fixing itself by
correcting and we are breaking it more
by intervening not the opposite way
around and until we do that we're never
gonna fix it why do you think that he
hasn't at least publicly kind of crossed
the chasm and and said hey this Bitcoin
thing is real do you think it's that he
doesn't understand it he doesn't believe
in it or it's more of a sleight of hand
and actually he's doing one thing behind
closed doors and not talking about it
publicly yeah dude this one's won I've
battled with for a long time so I mean
most of the writing that he does like
particularly prior writing that this one
I think there was a lot of if you asked
me that question
six months ago I would have probably
said it's the latter I think that you
know there's a bit of sleight of hand
going here and he's buying our Bitcoin
like a boss in the background but
reading this one I was like you know man
he's actually missing a few really
fundamental pieces like you know
intrinsic value being one of them and
you know presuppositions around you know
he's right about credit cycles but he's
defining everything within that paradigm
and you know he talks about these
paradigm shifts but he seems to be
unable to to acknowledge that Bitcoin is
an example of a paradigm shift you know
or or a phase shift something that is
different to what exists so he's either
there's either something really really
really not clicking for him with respect
to Bitcoin or he's just because he's got
such a
I guess a public presence it may be
dangerous too
you know publicly promote Bitcoin
because I mean you know you got this
hundred and what is it two hundred
billion dollar asset now which I mean if
he turns around and says you know
Bridgewater is allocating to Bitcoin you
know we're probably gonna we don't need
the having it'll be called the Dahlia
inning